this past weekend on her show MSNBC host
joy Reed offered an open invitation to
any one of the 217 House Republicans who
voted for the American Health Care Act
to show up on MSNBC and explain why did
you vote for this pretty simple right
217 people some of you must have some
idea why you voted for this thing come
and tell us
according to joy read nobody accepted
her offer these are their names and here
at am joy my tireless producers reached
out to each and every one of them to ask
them to join us today I offered each of
them the lead spot on this show this
morning to go one-on-one with me to
explain why they voted for the bill and
not a single one agree the names are
still scrolling there they are all those
names is still going 217 people no
takers
not a one AHA such bravery this is the
equivalent strategy that Trump
press-secretary took the other day when
he just walked out of the briefing room
without answering any questions why
would any of them want to show up Pat
and have to defend their vote how would
they even be able to most of them didn't
even read what they voted for yeah the
thing is that congressmen go on TV all
the time even though this is MSNBC
they'd be completely willing to do that
they just don't want to have to defend
the indefensible in this situation and
not only that they can't defend what
they're not familiar with and it's very
difficult to defend something you
haven't read it's also more difficult to
defend something that might hurt your
reelection chances if your constituents
realize you supported it when they start
losing their health care maybe after
they got the invitation they started
thumbing through the bill and said well
this is what I voted for this is a
really bad idea the last thing I want to
do is show up publicly and praise this
Trump and Republicans have been going on
and on for so long about wanting to
repeal Obamacare that now they would
sort of look like hypocritical clowns if
they didn't repeal it and have something
to replace it with so they've thrown
together this half-baked sort of
impromptu legislation that creates more
problems than it solves has critics on
the left and critics on the right and to
go on TV and say that would be pretty
embarrassing it also doesn't help
that the two most notable Republicans to
talk about the American healthcare act
on TV Mark Sanford and Chris Collins
fell flat on their face and had to admit
they didn't read it and they didn't
understand the provision and one of
those stories we talked about yesterday
I didn't know about the Sanford one but
he's got no shortage of embarrassing
appearances in his history so that's not
a big shocker to me so anyway I come on
one republican one of the 217 explain
exactly what is going to be great about
this bill because you can't really take
obamacare and move to the right and
lower cost increase quality of care and
increase access to care it just can't
happen so that's why they're not able to
defend it as such many discussions about
this on our reddit discussion forum i
encourage you to join us there at david
pakman.com slash re d di t today's
program is made possible in part by
Gamefly which is sort of like netflix
for video games they've got over 8,000
new and classic games for xbox one Xbox
360 ps4 ps3 Wii and a bunch of other
platforms and you can also stream games
you don't even need a gaming console or
a computer because you can stream games
through your Amazon fire stick or Roku
box and then use your mobile phone as
the controller you can play as many
games as you want
for one monthly fee and if you find some
games you want to keep you can buy them
for a low used price never with due
dates or late fees and our audience can
get a 30-day free trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included no contracts and you
can also stream the games I think I
mentioned that you can also rent games
through the mobile app get a free 30 day
trial for david pakman show viewers and
listeners and support our show at
Gamefly offer.com forward slash TDP s